[Music]
[Applause]
he's Ross Tucker Westwood One CBS Sports
NFL college football analyst former NFL
offensive lineman make sure you download
the draftking Sportsbook app and use the
promo code Patrick and uh draftking
Sportsbook promo code Patrick the crown
is yours and We Make Way for Ross Tucker
who joins us on the program what are the
odds that bill bellich Mike Vel and Pete
Carroll are not coaching in the NFL next
season very good at this point it seems
unlikely I mean a lot of people are
pointing towards Ben Johnson the Lions
offensive coordinator ending up in
Washington and then there's only one
spot left in Seattle some people still
think that'll be Dan Quinn obviously the
Ravens defensive coordinator is a young
star and Mike McDonald I don't know if I
Envision Vel going up there it's such an
interesting Dynamic Dan that I think
you'll appreciate
right A lot of these teams already have
their general manager in place yeah well
if you're Adam Peters and you're the new
GM in Washington and you know that there
was some conflict between Vel and ran
carthon do you want to bring Rael to
Washington I mean Peters and ran carthon
Dan were together out in San Francisco
for years John Schneider he just finally
got control right Pete Carroll remember
Pete Carroll had final say over the
roster in Seattle John Schneider finally
has total control does he want to bring
in somebody like VES who very likely
wants that power I mean that that's
where we're at now where some of these
more high-profile guys are basically
losing these power struggles and that's
why it took so long for Harbaugh and the
Chargers Harbaugh was not giving in
until he got the shuur one and the
Chargers gave it to him okay why is Bill
bellich not getting interviewed by any
other teams and why did he not get the
Falcons
job so let's start with the Falcons job
he didn't get the Falcons job
because he wanted what he wanted I think
he probably look there's two ways to
look at it either he overplayed his hand
or he's not going to coach unless he
gets what he wants but by all accounts
he wanted to report directly the owner
the Falcons have a structure in place
where they have a team president and
Rich McKay You Know Rich McKay doesn't
want to lose his power or lose his job
or whatever and so I think that was an
issue for people they you know you have
a GM and Terry fno he knows he's as good
as gone basically if belich gets the job
so I think that's tough for an owner
like Arthur blank if the two guys that
you're around all the time the GM font
know the president McKay are saying you
don't want bellich you know he's old and
look what he's done the last few years
you don't want that guy everybody in the
NFL Dan never forget this I know you
know this I'm saying this for the
audience everybody's out for themselves
everybody's looking out for their own
personal best interest and so a lot of
times that's how you're able to connect
the dots F no McKay they didn't want
bich I'm quite sure yeah but there's a
report that Arthur Blank did want bill
bellich is the feeling or the sense that
others talked him out of that for the
reasons or at least some of the reasons
you're saying well I think he
desperately wanted Bill bellich to be
the head coach I think Bill bellich
that's got to be hard I mean In fairness
to Bill 20 years where you're calling
all the shots and now you're not SHO for
any of the groceries you're just the
cook so to speak I think belich thought
it's just a guess I have no Insight
information but my guess is belich
thought or heard that blank wanted him
so bad that I think belich thought he
could be you know shopping for the
groceries and cooking the meal and blank
decided no he could probably cook a
better meal than we have for meat Friday
but that's that's a we have I heard
about that glad on here to cheer you up
who's what's like the decision making
hierarchy here because a couple weeks
ago when I filled in for you they said
what would you like and I said BRZ bam
BRZ I mean they had BRS when I request
them D because I like to put them in my
mustard cup as I'm driving back to
Pennsylvania after I fill in for you
yeah I mean I don't know what the
decision-making power is when you're
there but I asked for BRS and I got him
well I'm not an owner like David teer is
I let my people do do their job that's
what I do and I let Tyler do his job and
so when he said uh we have a chicken
stir fry and we have egg rolls and I
said it's called meat
Friday so would would tacos count for a
meat Friday if there's ground beef in
them or maybe pork in there yeah so the
issue is the chicken stir fry if it was
pork stir fry or be stir fry you'd be
okay you need to have me me it's it's
it's called a meat Friday it's not stir
fry stir Friday it's not egg roll Friday
you know Tyler made a mistake that's all
it's just but you know as an owner
that's what I do that uh I just pick him
up and I say hey dust him off hey we'll
have a better Friday next Friday we're
talking to Ross Tucker Ross is going to
be on the sidelines for Westwood One
Chiefs and the Ravens here give me the
non quarterback who will have the most
impact on on this game and then we'll do
the other
game uh that's a good question for the
AFC game the NFC game I think it's very
very obvious AFC game I'm gonna say
Travis Kelce it's hard to imagine the
Chiefs winning in my mind if he doesn't
have a really good game you know a lot
of people thought this year was the
first example Dan where he really wasn't
quite what he has been you know that
maybe he's lost a little bit yeah had a
really good game against the bills last
week had two touchdowns was still a
major factor in that game I think that's
kind of the key matchup unlike the bills
the Ravens have two really good off the-
ball linebackers and they have a safety
who actually matches up well with Kelsey
Kyle Hamilton's like 64
215 he's like the Prototype to be able
to cover a tight end like Kelce manto
man so if kelse has a really good game I
think the Chiefs have a chance it's hard
for me to picture talking on Monday
about the Chiefs winning the game if
Kelsey doesn't have a big game so I'll
go Kelce all right what about the
Ravens oh both teams okay um
non-quarterback for the
Ravens uh I'm gonna I'm going to go
defensive side of the ball and I'm going
to say Justin
matab this guy had 13 sacks and this is
a key thing to for people to note that
other people won't talk about enough I
don't think Joe Toney the all proo left
guard is gonna play for the Chiefs so
now now they got a backup journeyman
Ross Tucker type going up against a guy
that had 13 sacks in a career you don't
want that like you don't you don't want
me or someone like me going against
matab one-on-one in obvious passing situ
uations so Alec ready he's played before
he's solid you know he hopefully won't
lose the game did you ever have a
defensive lineman who was outright giddy
to face
you
um I don't know if I'd say that but oh
so you're gonna love
this 2002 okay I get cut by Washington
picked up on waivers by the Cowboys the
guy in front of me gets so I'm starting
at left guard for whatever reason Larry
Allen has a bad ankle so they list him
as questionable almost every week Dan
like at least the first four weeks they
might have eventually put him on IR but
at least the first three or four weeks
he was questionable and he was the
Cowboys left guard I was basically
filling in for him Dan I have never seen
defensive players so happy to see me in
my entire life every week when I went
out there they looked at me and they
were like oh thank God it's this dude
and not Larry Allen so yes they were
giddy that they were playing against me
and not Larry Allen that's for sure okay
The X Factor for the Niners X Factor for
the Lions will be who okay this is easy
and I didn't even know this to this
extent till ear earlier in the week it's
Debo Samuel so I do a betting podcast
part of the DraftKings Network it's
called the even money betting podcast
and I found out this week I never would
have guessed this Debo Samuel is the
most valuable non-quarterback skill
player in the NFL against the spread
yeah I have I called my co-host out on
it Dan and I said wait wait wait wait
they have Brandon auk George KD mcaffrey
and Debo's that important I didn't know
this the ners average two yards more per
play when Debo's in the lineup than when
he's not that equates to one and a half
to two points against the spread I've
never heard of a quarterback being that
valuable according to the odds makers
and the professional betters as Debo
Samuel one half two points non
quarterback non quarterback non
quarterback also the ners are 12- one
straight up and 10 and3 against the
spread when Debo starts in finishes a
game they're 1 and four straight up and
0 and5 against the spread when he
doesn't so that adds even more influence
to what you're uh pointing out there so
you got Debo for the ners don't know if
he's going to play and how much and then
the Lions X
factors you know I'm gonna say I'll say
uh alen mcneel and Aiden Hutchinson I
think they got a dominate up front
McNeil's the D tackle Hutchinson's the D
end you know the Lions Corners are not
good I'm a little surprised Aaron Glenn
plays as much man coverage as he does
they're probably going to draft the
corner and sign one in for agency
because both those guys struggle they
gotta stop the run and they need to get
pressure get hery in the obvious passing
Downs because he's not great he's much
better play action much better first and
second down passer third down obvious
passing Downs I think those guys working
against especially the right side of the
ners o line like Aiden hson against
mckivitz that is a matchup the Lions can
and let's be honest they have to win
that Hutchinson has to have a big game
going against mckivitz off the right
side safe travels to Baltimore and uh
we'll talk to you next week thank you
sounds great it's a very short drive
I'll likely be wearing my orange jacket
on the chief sideline trying to steal as
much TV time as I can all right we'll
play the game of h fine Ross Tucker on
the sidelines there Ross joining us on
behalf of draftking Sportsbook and uh
use the promo code Patrick new customers
can bet just five bucks get 200
instantly in bonus bets only on
draftking sports book promo code Patrick
the crown is yours thank you Ross my
pleasure thank you Dan that's the lovely
and talented Ross Tucker from Westwood
One he'll be on the sidelines for the
he's the sideline reporter for the
Chiefs and the Ravens he'll be on the
Chiefs sideline